me acabo de dar cuenta que está orinando
es muy bien está el cambio muchas cosas
[Aplausos]
yo soy tutora y también hago modelaje y
la creación de contenido web me encanta
la idea de los tatuajes creo que es algo
increíble poder decorar pse con el arte
que te gusta qué tipo de tatuaje
simboliza para ti una advertencia que es
lo que si lo ves
tal vez una cita bíblica o algo como una
cita de vida tampoco soy la mayor fan de
una rosa y una daga no es algo que me
guste
muy bien me gusta que no se la calavera
sino como una caja torácica
el arroz y la daga y si te ofendí antes
lo siento mucho pero tienes un caracol
genial y hay un reloj que también hay un
montón de piezas de tiempo aquí lo que
es interesante me gusta como éstos
parecen que podrían ser tatuajes de
viernes 13 me encantan
todos son geniales creo que todos ellos
son bastante diferentes especialmente
las lunas que tienes ahí 8.1
me gusta la lentitud de todos ellos etc
en seguida pienso que es un hermoso
trabajo de línea líneas realmente
nítidas este es un pequeño tren en
marcha
no estoy muy segura pero me gusta creo
que también encajan muy bien juntos eso
es algo que es muy importante tenerlos
incorporados estos hermosos 18.6
si un tatuaje tipo manga puedo ver que
dice esto aquí eternamente agradecido es
bueno saberlo un pájaro también tengo un
pájaro me gusta los pájaros hay algo en
el interior de su brazo wow tienes una
rosa es un tatuaje de abuela y un
recuerdo supongo muy bonito por supuesto
no es de mi estilo pero sigue siendo un
buen tatuaje un 7.3
este es realmente bonito este sí me
gusta soy una gran fan de los tatuajes
de serpiente y también tengo uno en el
antebrazo también tengo una calavera así
que estoy realmente bonita 7.9
y
creo que esto es un querubín que también
tengo
sin embargo no tiene alias es como un
bebé desnudo lo cual puedo respetar me
acabo de dar cuenta de que está
brindando muy bien esto cambia muchas
cosas sigue sin ser un mal tatuaje es
una elección aún más audaz le daré un
6.9
tendré que
eliminar el número cinco lo siento mucho
creo que estaba un poco impactada
es un gran tatuaje porque no te gusta
vamos
vamos es adorable si no es adorable y
también me encanta
definitivamente entiendo que no es para
todo el mundo pero sigue siendo
muy bien tiene algún significado este
árbol o simplemente es bonito y te gusta
cuando era niño perdí a mi abuelo a una
edad muy temprana siente mucho oírla así
que su muerte me afectó de manera
tremenda mi madre para hacerme sentir
mejor solo me aseguro que ya sabéis ahí
vida después de morir y dijo en el cielo
siempre nos encontraremos junto a un
gran arco es una historia preciosa
gracias por compartir
muy interesante bonito color de uñas
esto es un extra o belong si es
relacionado con tu árbol bien tiene esta
algún significado para ti voy a jugar
mucho con nuestro vilos con mi hermanita
y ella es la persona más importante del
mundo para meter ni sipe mucho en su
crianza entonces quise hacerme un
tatuaje para conmemorar eso tengo
curiosidad por ver si hay algún color
si hay más un genial maya me gusta las
nubes es una manga muy significativa
para ti sí por supuesto tienes algo más
arriba en el hombro
este vamos arriba realmente me gusta
como todos encajan muy bien juntos todo
tiene una temática muy similar todos se
relacionan conviven juntos
resumiendo cuando tenía 19 años tuve un
accidente de auto rompí la espalda y
siento que dios me dio una segunda
oportunidad en la línea entonces
básicamente ahí es donde todo se junta
siempre agradecido los números romanos
el día en que tuve el accidente de auto
también me alegra saber que estás bien
sin muchos accidentes a diario
tatuajes en las piernas pero era como no
se iba a mostrar estilo supongo
entiendo soy fan de las converse
de nuevo todos estos son grandes
tatuajes
espero que no tome es mi eliminación
como algo personal tendré que eliminar
al concursante número 3
me rompe el corazón
[Risas]
dónde están sus tatuajes veamos lo que
tienes ya bueno ya te la dan solo quiero
mirar que tienes
no hay mucho que pueda mostrar con mis
brazos porque están algo dispersos los
amo
veo que dos de ustedes tienen zapatos
similares muy bonitos me gusta el
concursante número dos me gusta su me
gusta como dejas los tatuajes para que
yo los recuerde muy bueno yo creo que
tienes un pequeño rayo bonito
por supuesto a qué se dedican ustedes
soy asistente de producción soy
ingeniero de sonido normalmente trabajo
con bandas en vivo estudio y también
quería una aplicación fantástica que
soy héctor a tiempo parcial pero también
trabajo en investigación que limpian
está me encantan las dos caras de una
misma moneda esto tenían para que te
dedicas para vivir soy tutor actualmente
en se llama neumáticas van a los
estudiantes de primaria más jóvenes que
están entre segundo y quinto grado y
también hago modelaje y creo contenido
guapas y una gran fan de la moda y el
maquillaje todo lo que tenga que ver con
la belleza también me gustan los juegos
pienso hacer streaming pronto
posiblemente queda uno de ustedes 25
tengo 23 21
no hay nada de malo en eso es genial
esta
desgracia tendrá que ser
el concursante y número 3 sólo porque
soy mayor que tú
no es malo para nadie los viernes 23
lo siento escuchen lo siento mucho yo lo
sé
el siguiente concursante que tendré que
eliminar será el concursante número 1 de
nuevo lo siento mucho soy sólo una
extraña por favor no te lo tomes apec no
hay problema me encantan los muebles
compartimos algo
[Risas]
[Música]
también me encanta el tuyo pero ya lo
sabes hortalà también cantan tus
pendientes
para la moda de la manga pero por si
éste es mi ambos tenemos al serpientes
sí tengo muchas flores tengo una
calavera pájaros al azar por aquí y
tienes un dolor de ojos muy bonito sí
aquí los nuevos son falsos pero sabes no
pasa nada
contentos con la elección que has hecho
movimiento de nada
cualquier
número usarán algún plan para salir
podemos sentar muy bien ya jugar un poco
de valor ante
un rival muy útil comenzamos bien un
fantástico
bien es que pienso en ustedes creen que
tomó la decisión no lo hizo
no puede manejarme entonces
muchas gracias fue muy divertido
espectacular
[Risas]